-Hey, Senator Sanders.
You look great.
Really good to see you again.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thanks for having me, Jimmy.
-There's a lot to talk about.
First, I'd love to get your
thoughts on last night's debate.
-Well, what I think is that
it was certainly not as crazy
a debate as the first debate.
-Yeah.
-But I continue to be astounded
by the degree
to which Donald Trump lies --
just lies and lies and lies --
not only his lies,
his downplaying of this
terrible pandemic from Day One
is just astounding to me.
And I hope the American people
understand that
because of his irresponsibility,
because of his rejection
of science,
his attacks on Dr. Fauci,
that tens of thousands of people
have died unnecessarily.
-One of the things
I admired about you
is that you endorsed
Vice President Biden,
although you don't agree
with him on every issue.
I just think that sends a --
what -- what message
are you sending there?
-Well, the message is that --
let me be very frank --
and not everybody
will agree with me,
but I think that Donald Trump
is the most dangerous president
in the modern history
of this country,
and it's not just because
he lies all the time.
It's not just because
he doesn't believe in science.
he's a racist or a sexist
or a homophobe or a xenophobe,
it is because
he is quite intentionally
trying to undermine
American democracy,
trying to suppress the vote.
We are a democratic society.
People have fought and died
to defend our democracy,
and we cannot re-elect
the president
who does not believe
in the rule of law,
our Constitution,
or, in fact, our democracy.
I have known Joe
for many, many years.
He is a very decent guy.
As you have indicated,
he and I have differences of
opinions on a number of issues.
But I can vouch for his decency
and his belief in the rule
of law and democracy.
-When was the first time --
do you remember
meeting Joe Biden,
Vice President?
-Oh, I do. You know, he was
a senator, and I was a senator.
He was around
for a very long time.
I was new.
And the thing I think
that people will learn
bout Joe Biden --
he is a very, very
down-to-earth guy.
My wife remembers the first time
that she met him,
and she never, you know,
talked to him at all.
He sat down, and he chatted
with her about Ireland --
their families
both come from Ireland.
-Yeah.
-Very -- Very human guy.
A very empathetic guy.
-Although the election
is November 3rd,
and it's been said that
we won't know the results
until days later,
when do you think
we'll know the results?
-Jimmy, you raise
an important point,
and I hope the American
people understand it,
because this is something
I worry about.
My view is every vote
must be counted.
For reasons which I don't have
the time to get into tonight,
you're going to have
a situation, I suspect,
in states like Pennsylvania,
Michigan, Wisconsin,
other states,
where they
are going to be receiving
huge amounts of mail-in ballots.
And unlike states
like Florida or Vermont,
they're not able,
for bad reasons,
to begin processing
those ballots until --
I don't know -- Election Day
or maybe when the polls close.
That means
you're going to have states
dealing with perhaps millions
of mail-in ballots.
Here is my worry.
What polls show,
and what studies have shown
is that, for whatever reason,
Democrats are more likely
to use mail-in ballots.
Republicans are more likely
to walk into polling booths
on Election Day.
It is likely that the first
votes that will be counted
will be those people
who came in on Election Day,
which will be Republican.
And here is the fear --
and I hope everybody hears it --
it could well be --
you know,
I don't know what's going to
happen -- nobody does.
But it could well be that,
at 10:00 on election night,
Trump is winning in Michigan,
he's winning in Pennsylvania,
he's winning in Wisconsin,
and he gets on the television
and he says,
"Thank you, Americans,
for re-electing me.
It's all over.
Have a good day."
But then, the next day
and the day following,
all of those mail-in ballots
start getting counted,
and it turns out that Biden
has won those states.
At which point Trump says,
"See? I told whole thing
was fraudulent.
I told you those mail-in ballots
were crooked.
And I got -- you know, we're not
going to leave office."
So that is a worry
that I and a lot of people have.
So, the results -- you know,
we don't know what's happened.
-Sure.
-Maybe the results will be known
on election night.
But people should be aware
of that possibility.
-I know that
you have been working
with people running in Texas.
Why is Texas important now?
I feel like a lot of people
are highlighting Texas.
-I think that Texas may be --
in many ways,
Texas is the future of
progressive politics in America.
Historically, because there has
been a lot of voter suppression,
Texas is one of the states
where their Republican
state government has,
for a long time,
tried to make it as difficult
as possible for people to vote.
But you have folks over there --
Beto O'Rourke and others
are doing a great job
registering people,
getting people to vote.
The bottom line is that if Texas
becomes a blue state
and a progressive state,
as I think it can --
it has a lot of young people.
It has a lot of Latinos,
a lot of African-Americans.
It can become
a progressive state.
And if that happens,
and if those 38 electoral votes
go Democratic,
then we've changed the face
of American politics.
-Wow.
I think that would be --
that would be -- I mean,
are people predicting that?
Or this is just your people?
-There's no question
the trend is with us.
What we don't know is how
it plays out this election.
And to those people out there
who say,
"Oh, Texas is
a conservative state" --
trust me, it is not.
You have some great,
great progressive candidates
who are running for office
who stand a great chance to win,
and the future is with
progressive politics in Texas.
-It will be interesting to watch
what happens in Texas.
Bernie Sanders, thank you so
much for coming back to my show.
And give my best
to the grandkids.
I know we always talk about them
every time you're on.
And, God, you always smile
every time I bring them up.
But I appreciate you
coming back on the show.
It means a lot to me,
so thank you.
Senator Bernie Sanders,
everyone.